this is conmigo an AI powered guide
designed to help all students learn
conmigo is not just for students though
teachers can use conmigo too by toggling
from student mode to teacher mode once
in teacher mode kigo transforms into the
teaching assistant you've always wanted
conmigo has many exciting features that
support teachers and this video will
showcase ways teachers can use conmigo
to track their students progress this
feature is called the class snapshot
once the class snapshot feature is
selected kigo will ask you which course
do you want to use the class snapshot
for I'm going to select Algebra 1 once
that button is selected kigo Springs
into action and tells me how my students
have performed the last seven days in my
course kigo will show me their learning
time kigo will show me how they're
performing on their assignments how
they're performing on their skills and
how they are performing in towards their
Mastery goals kigo also includes
additional prompts to help guide me into
diving into my students data such as
which student should I celebrate for
their work on their assignments who
needs a check in about their skills
progress for the week give me a list of
students who are above 25% on their
Mastery goal and I think this one may be
my favorite group my class by their
recommendations this feature really does
help me when I want to do skill-based
group instruction when I select the who
needs a check-in about their skills
progress for the week conmigo creates a
list of students that they think I
should check on who may need a nudge in
the course because they haven't been
leveling up two skills per week I'm able
to see the list of students and again
conmigo gives me a helpful link that I
could click on that will give me direct
access to the report that I need after
having my data chats with my students
who are struggling I can also use
conmigo to help me draft an email that I
can send home to parents about their
students
progress
create a parent letter for
Paul about his
progress and then I just let kigo do con
Migo's
magic this is wonderful thank you so
much kigo
oops I totally forgot Paul's mom speaks
Spanish could you
please
translate this to
Spanish again one click of the button
and my email is ready to go to Paul's
Mom this is an amazing feature thank you
so much kigo I appreciate all of your
help you have saved me so much time
thanks so much for watching and be on
the lookout for more videos to come on
how to use kigo to support your students